McCarthy is uh is stepping up and listen
to his statement on what's going on with
Trump right now
it doesn't matter what side of the issue
you're on it doesn't matter if this was
President Trump or if this was a
Democrat
it should be equal justice in America
and stop going after people because you
have political differences I don't think
people should protest this no and I I
think president Trump if you talk to him
he doesn't believe that either I mean I
think I think the thing that you may
misinterpret when the when President
Trump talks
when someone says that they can protest
he would probably be referring to my
tweet educate people about what's going
on he's not talking in a harmful way and
nobody should nobody should harm one
another okay so you could see that what
the media was trying to do there was lay
the trap again because Trump on Truth
social put out there that you know
people should protest in honor of this
or in in protest of this you know this
nonsensical farce you could see the way
the MSNBC clowns and the rest of the
media ah you see he's trying to get
people out there again January 6th again
here we go of course nothing has
happened and he didn't say violently
protest and he didn't say burn anything
down or shoot anybody or anything else
but the point of all of this is that
this is all leading to 24 right like
that's what this is all about obviously
they don't want Trump they don't want
the Santa's either and they'll deal with
as I said they they're going to call uh
DeSantis Trump with a calculator once
they figure out how to get rid of trump
so like there's a Litany of things that
these people can do and there's almost
no bottom to that to that hole where
they will always go to to just do
horrible things but a lot of it could
backfire you know just remember like in
America anything can happen
[Music]
oh